flavie flament bonsoir mince affaire
j'ai adoré ma vie d'enfants et
d'adolescents en normandie j'ai déclaré
ça dans madame figaro en juillet 2002 et
aujourd'hui le livre que vous publiez
chez lattès la consolation fait voler en
éclats cette idyllique tableau fanni en
effet il lève le voile sur une enfance
dicté par la folie d'une mère dépressive
et manipulatrice prête à jeter sa fille
dans les bras du premier prédateur venu
en échange d'un court instant de strass
et de paillettes se passe et flavie vous
l'aviez refoulé effacé de votre mémoire
mais il a refait surface vous dites que
ça a commencé par un malaise boulevard
malesherbes vous croyez devenir folle ça
faisait quelques temps déjà que j'étais
en souffrance fin je l'avais toujours
été mais j'étais incapable d'en
connaître réellement l'origine et
d'ailleurs je me construisait une vie ou
j'imaginais une vie même à passer même
une famille
finalement qui n'avait en réalité jamais
existé et la mort de mon grand-père a
été déterminante parce que c'était la
seule personne qui pour moi représente
ait un lien secure c'était une personne
qui m'aimait sans condition et ce jour
là boulevard malesherbes jeu j'ai vécu
un 1er surgissement un premier
jaillissement de ce que l'on appelle la
mémoire traumatique qui sont
effectivement tous ces souvenirs intacts
qui sont refoulés au fond de soi dans un
coin de votre âme c'est une sorte de
fantôme c'est un assaillant il est sur
votre épaule il vient troubler tous vos
moments de bonheur il vient gâcher votre
regard sur l'existence il vous harcèle
mais vous ne savez pas qui il est et
vous ne savez pas ce qui se passe c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai cru devenir
folle or les malaises vont se répéter
régulièrement avec des crises de panique
bientôt des flashs voyez un tissu vers
un ciel bleu derrière un mur blanc
jusqu'au jour où après avoir tout essayé
vous contré un psychiatre qui vous
demandent de revenir avec un album photo
de votre enfance mais reprenons les
choses par le commencement
flavie lecanu ce votre vrai nom vous
naissez le 2 juillet 1974 à valognes
dans la manche votre père ancien
footballeur boss la sncf et votre mère
s'occupe d'enfants de la dass à la
maison vous avez deux frères cadets on
ne peut pas dire que vos parents vous
porte une grande attention vous raconter
dans votre livre qu'un soir après un
match de foot ils vous disent reste dans
la voiture on va boire un coup et vous
oublie dans la voiture un moment vous
sortez de la voiture il fait nuit vous
avez peur vous les rejoignent et les
vous calcule pas c'est temps en parlant
à jour en expliquant mais je me souviens
avoir couru avoir ouvert 7/7 cette porte
être arrivé avoir vu que dès que des
jambes d'adultes parce que j'étais
minuscule et avoir traversé ce salon et
j'ai souvenir de quelque chose qui
vraiment et douloureux et c'est là qu'il
m'a été rapporté effectivement d'une
façon d'ailleurs assez déroutante parce
que absolument déculpabiliser c'est là
que j'ai entendu ben oui flavie ce jour
là effectivement c'est dingue que tu
t'en souviennes on avait oublié il ya
autre chose c'est que le soir quand vous
êtes au lit votre père passe dans la
chambre de vos deux frères pour en faire
un bisou et vous vous calcule toujours
pas s'il avoue est là tout seul en train
de vous enfuir dans notre rayé pour
pleurer il y avait une relation avec mon
père je dis avec papa d'ailleurs parce
que je lui porte toujours un véritable
amour mais il y avait un malaise quand
on était ensemble et on éviter les
moments où on pouvait se retrouver tous
les deux c'est la raison pour laquelle
je pense tous les soirs quand il naît à
embrasser mes frères au lieu de prendre
le couloir et de venir m'embrasser mois
ils redescendent l escalier directement
votre mère est beaucoup plus sévère
quand elle vous reproche d'avoir pris du
cul comme elle dit elle vous oblige à
des régimes elle nous oblige à des
pesées et quand arrive le dessert à
table elle vous diva dans la voiture
comme ça tu vas pas craqué oui c'est à
dire que le mon poids devient une
obsession avec la balance du matin avec
une observation permanente des courbes
de mon corps mais en plus ça vous coûte
de l'enfance vous êtes déjà dans la
restriction au moment où vous êtes en
train de tout l'été quoi est elle adore
cette mère quand les hommes plus âgés
vous relu que ça les moustiques quoi en
fait je me suis souvent interrogé
essayer de comprendre les raisons qui
avaient qu'il aurait pu expliquer de ce
comportement et je ne veux pas aller
chercher donc j'imagine qu'effectivement
il y avait un ennui abyssal heureusement
notre maire organise des week-ends à
paris entre filles c'est pas le louvre
c'est pas la tour eiffel s'est parée de
triomphe mais c'est des enregistrements
d'émissions de télévision comme champs
elysées par exemple son truc c'est
d'approché de célébrités elle veut vivre
une vie qu'elle n'aurait pas pu toucher
du doigt si je n'avais pas été ce que
j'étais à 13 ans votre mère vous emmène
au cap d'agde alors devant tous ces gens
à poil devant tous ces sex vous passez
vite de l'étonnement à l'écoeurement à
la nausée et c'est là qu'un photographe
vous branche vous et votre mère
d'ailleurs voulant faire des essais avec
vous votre mère est aux anges les essais
sont un succès et rendez vous est pris
pour faire de vraies photos et dès lors
tous les jours votre mère vous dépose à
14 heures chez le photographe en disant
je la récupère à quelle heure passé
l'après-midi que ce photographe oui et
est ce qui en fait ne me surprend je
passe plusieurs heures l'après midi chez
le photographe mais c'est cette phrase
vient la chercher à quelle heure et je
me souviens déjà tout petit enfin
j'avais 13 ans mais dit mais je suis
plus un bébé quoi et puis jusqu'au jour
où un jour la porte s'ouvre le
photographe est à poil
votre mère lâche vote n'en ai dit je la
récupère à quelle heure c'est la même
chose comme si de rien n'était a dit
exactement la même phrase alors le
photographe commence par vous emmener
sur la plage pour que vous a pas tjrs et
des femmes pour lui vous êtes pénalisé
devant ces femmes nues il vous décrit
leur sexe etc enfin bon et là il
s'énerve et ils vous ramène dans son
appartement et là il viole deux fois une
fois sur le balcon et une fois sous la
douche
il commence sur le balcon et ils
m'emmènent sous la douche c'est le même
jour et
je c'est là que je je je recompose
finalement le film puisque vous parliez
de ces images qui me revenaient d'une
façon totalement désordonnée ce mur en
crépi blanc et ce coin de ciel bleu
c'est précisément le moment où je suis
allongé sur le balcon et c'est ce que je
vois il vous tend une serviette verte et
c'est bien ce bout de tissu que vous
avez revu à partir du boulevard
malesherbes quand les choses ont
commencé à remonter à la surface violet
à 13 ans oui c'est à dire morte de
l'intérieur fissure est morte pas
complètement heureusement parce que
c'est toujours une flamme en moi et puis
surtout je pense qu'il ya il ya déjà ce
fameux phénomène extraordinaire que l'on
méconnaît encore peut-être de la mémoire
traumatique fait que ce que je suis en
train de vivre finalement je ne suis pas
là pour le vivre j'ai abandonné notre
corps à part vivre le moment j'ai
abandonné mon corps j'ai abandonné
poupette cette petite fille que j'étais
le surnom que me donner mon grand père
qui l'a abandonné ce jour là sur le
balcon et et gc c'est une dissociation
en fait c'est le cerveau qui est
extraordinaire qui fait que lorsque
votre santé psychique et mise en danger
votre cerveau va vous permettre à un
moment donné de ne plus être dans la
sensation donc vous n'êtes plus rien
vous êtes entre les bras d'un pervers
vous êtes dans les mains d'un pédophile
et vous n'êtes pas là alors vous savez
que ces séances photos permettent à
votre mère de briller alors vous n'allez
pas lui dire maman je pus me faire
violer l'après midi vous lui dites j'en
ai marre en fait de passer mais après
midi enfermé avec ce type je préfèrerais
aller me baigner et votre main vous
réponds quand on prend un engagement on
va jusqu'au bout oui c'est vrai quand on
prend un engagement va jusqu'au bout
c'est ce que je suis en train de lire
jusqu'au bout puisque vous êtes là ce
soir
alors voilà tous les jours jusqu'à la
fin des vacances vous irez vous faire
violer par le célèbre photographe
je vais pas me faire violer je suis
violer
c'est important pardon les prix mais une
victime ne se fait pas violer comme on
se fait une couleur de cheveux ou comme
on se fait refaire les dents une victime
et violée quand j'entends flavie flament
avoue avoir été violée c'est pas à moi
d'avouer c'est aux coupables de faire
l'aveux justement bus comme on est là
secoue pas pourquoi vous donnait pas son
nom je ne peux pas donner son nom parce
que j'ai aujourd'hui 42 ans et que
j'avais selon la loi française jusqu'à
l'âge de 38 ans pour pouvoir leur
tournée contre mon bourreau donc je peux
dire en au passage pardon flavie mais
c'est que il ya des députés et des
sénateurs qui ont voulu porter ce délai
à 48 absolument à 48 ans et ça a été un
rejeter c'était en 2014 si la loi était
passé vous pourriez dire le mans de ce
photographe à le faire aujourd'hui il
serait poursuivi oui et je ne peux pas
le faire aujourd'hui parce que je suis
non seulement victime mais je pourrais
être en plus accusé de diffamation est
ce que je peux donner son nom c'est à
vous de voir tiens
il a aujourd'hui 83 ans je suis pas si
regarde 1 télé mettez un bel en q les
connards
le 19 juin 1988 vous êtes élue miss ok
magazine sur m6 vous partez à tahiti
avec votre mère tout passe pas mal oui
ça se passe plutôt bien il ya un mec
quand même qu essayer de vous coincer
dans l'ascenseur mais un moment la porte
s'ouvre à issor oui est-ce que je relate
la à travers cette situation c'est que
je j'ai déjà vécu
le viol est en fait les prédateurs
sexuels reconnaissent leurs victimes
reconnaissent d'aider des jeunes femmes
qui dont l'intégrité a déjà été
piétinées et effectivement ce jour-là
j'échappe de justesse à une agression
sexuelle l'hiver suivant vous allez en
colonie de vacances à la montagne dans
le train vous rencontrez un garçon plus
âgé que vous voulez mais bien et à un
moment il va rentrer dans les données
dans les toilettes du train dévolues
fait un bisou tu fais un smack ouais
voilà il vous entraîne à l'intérieur des
toilettes il vous pénètre le fait de ne
pas pouvoir parler le fait de ne pas
pouvoir être entendu le fait de ne pas
pouvoir compter parfois sur un entourage
qui prendrait notre défense fait qu' on
ne sait plus dire non c'est ce qui s'est
passé ce jour là en train tu ne penses
pas que ce garçon est tt mal
intentionnés à moi mais je pense surtout
que je n'ai pas su dire non parce que je
ne savais pas ce que c'était que dire
non parce que je ne savais pas que ce
corps qui était le mien finalement
n'appartenait qu'à moi et n'appartenait
à personne d'autre et claire voilà vous
enfui c'est tout ça au plus profond de
votre mémoire les week-ends à paris
n'ont pas cessé avec votre mère vous
allez aux champs-elysées alors vous
montez vous descendez les champs
l'objectif c'est séduire les hommes
alors votre père vous a appris à sourire
à jouer avec vos cheveux à tortiller du
cul à lancer des oeillades mais ce qu'il
faut dire quand même c'est qu'à l'époque
la halle vous couchez pas avec les mecs
que vous allumez pas du tout c'est un
jeu wii mais je pense que chacun doit
rester à sa place dans une relation
parent enfant je moi je crois pas au
concept de copains merco pin je n'y
crois pas et moi j'ai été justement sous
couvert d'une sorte d'image fabuleuse
d'un couple super murphy qui s'entend si
bien en fait se cacher en réalité une
véritable relation reese bottemer
djouassa avec vous mais quand ne voulait
plus jouer elle fait la gueule c'est
quand on quand on est en manque d'amour
on ferait n'importe quoi pour nos
parents nous m un jour vous avez toutes
les deux ici à la plaine saint denis là
où sont tournées la plupart des
émissions de télévision en espérant y
rencontrer un célèbre animateur vous
êtes perdus au milieu de la foule des
fans votre mère vous pince les hanches
en vous poussant vers lui comme salim et
par lui c'est surtout que le lendemain
de ça parce que elle avait été obligée
de me pincer les hanches pour qu'à un
moment donné je fasse un bond en avant
de douleur et que je demande ce [ __ ]
autographes dont je me foutait
royalement le lendemain on était dans le
train et elle me dit tu te rends compte
si j'avais ta gueule et si tu avais mon
intelligence et ça aussi ça fait partie
de ces phrases qui m'ont poursuivi très
longtemps où j'ai eu le sentiment de
n'être rien ou en tout cas d'être un
physique qui était entretenu à coups de
régime mais qui avait rien à l'intérieur
de moi alors elle elle considère qu'elle
a une vie de merde un jour elle est
devant la gazinière elle tourne le
bouton en disant je vais mourir c'est un
moment de désespoir je pense aussi que
c'était quelqu'un qui
était en proie à un profond désespoir
dont je sais absolument pas de connaître
la cause mais mais oui ce jour là elle a
tourné le bouton du gaz vous la prenez
dans vos bras et s'avoue révulse oui
parce que vous êtes quand même même si
vous êtes dans la souffrance capable
d'identifier ceux qui vous font du mal
et il ya des pots qui sont douces au
toucher et qui rassure il y en a
d'autres qui sont froides et qui font
peur à l'âge de 16 ans vous rencontrez
un homme chez qui vous allez passer des
week-ends
ma mère est censé être ma copine donc
donc je me retrouve à avoir une vie qui
n'est pas du tout l'avis que je devrais
avoir à l'âge de 14 ans ou à l'âge de 15
ans et du coup quand ma mère regarde des
hommes ce sont des hommes de son âge et
elle trouve du charme
à un homme qui effectivement à plus de
25 ans de plus que moi et finalement
une histoire s'installe absolument folle
où je pars certains week-ends chez lui
et entre temps
s'installe une relation épistolaire
entre lui et moi sauf qu'en réalité
c'est votre mère qui est là c'est pas
moi et dans les lettres elle dit que
vous avez hâte de le revoir elle vient
me voir et elle me dit tu sais si tu
veux lui écrire moi je pense que tu
devrais écrire ce que j'ai écrit ma
lettre et mieux rédiger ça se passera
mieux ce sera mieux comme ça et donc du
coup il m'arrive parfois à l'heure de d2
voire de réécrire de mon écriture
la lettre qu'elle a qu'elle a rédigée
oui je me retrouve avec cet homme son
odeur d'hommes perdu veuf seul temu la
quarantaine
oui c'est un homme triste heureusement
heureusement au milieu de tout simple à
vivre pourrait compter sur un formidable
twitter de résilience si votre grand
père oui il est au courant de rien lui
sauf que il a cette façon de me faire
voir l'existence il a cette façon de mai
mais d'un amour que je considère comme
incommensurables dans ma vie c'est un
soleil donc je sais qu'on peut tendre
vers le soleil je sais qu'à un moment
donné on peut marcher et qu'on peut
choisir son trottoir donc au fond de moi
toujours je vais aller me réchauffer à
son soleil à lui c'est la raison pour
laquelle tout est parti quand il quand
il s'éteint alors aujourd'hui ça va
mieux non la psychothérapie vous a
permis de sortir de votre dépression
flavie poupette la petite fille que
j'étais m'a permis de sortir de tout ça
parce que j'ai un jour choisi d'aller la
chercher au fond de moi est ce que vous
voyez votre mère non jamais non c'est
une des premières étapes seront les plus
difficiles pour guérir on est obligé de
couper les liens avec ce qui nous est
toxique ce que je voudrais dire
avant de finir c'est que lee va super
bien écrit mais vraiment et il ya
beaucoup de témoignages on en lit
beaucoup celui-là est super bien écrit
vous avez vraiment un don pour écrire
merci merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus